[Music]
you're watching good day las vegas with
john langler
heather mills
sheri swensk and nate tannenbaum
good day las vegas live local now all
right it's coming up on a quarter to
seven time to see what's trending with
las vegas now host mercedes martinez oh
there she is joining us live from the
mix 94.1 studio good morning mercedes
good morning you two so great to see you
here is what's trending first up a new
beauty brand from pop star harry styles
it is called pleasing and it is a gender
neutral brand that is inspired by some
of the things that he uses in his own
beauty routine styles says that he
really wants his products to highlight
people and make them feel beautiful you
can pre-order pleasing online right now
well turning from one harry to another
harry potter fans are celebrating the
can you believe it 20th anniversary
of the wizards first film harry potter
and the sorcerer's stone the movie is
still the highest grossing film in the
franchise earning over 8 billion dollars
now the movie's director chris columbus
he recently expressed interest in
directing a new harry potter film based
on the broadway show the cursed child
john heather are you guys big harry
potter fans and if so what do you belong
to
i have seen
i i'm not i am i haven't i haven't
invested enough in harry potter i kind
of miss the harry potter train i need to
jump on the harry potter i'm a
gryffindor okay definitely mercedes
i totally knew you were a gryffindor
heather i knew it i'm a gryffindor too
and if i just had to predict john i
think you would be a ravenclaw heather d
that's what i was thinking too wow
mercedes yeah we're we're in tune today
is that a good thing
yeah i mean it's harry potter
backhanded insult but i wouldn't have
expected
slytherin then maybe it was a little
questionable
speaking of magic by the way you know
we're coming up on thanksgiving getting
ready for the feast magic in the kitchen
the question is mercedes what if we
can't wait for for thanksgiving what if
we need to get our thanksgiving fix now
yeah i've got another option for you and
it's at your nearby 7-eleven they're
selling a new thanksgiving sandwich that
has bread that is supposed to taste like
stuffing it comes with butterball turkey
it has white cheddar it has cranberry
mail and they only cost five bucks john
heather
stuffing bread i mean stuff yourself
with stuffing bread mercedes let's let's
call let's be honest here you can sure
spend five dollars at 7-eleven or you
can do it the right way and go to
capriatas and get the bobby and call it
a day
i was gonna say that you know we love
our friends at 7-eleven fair enough yeah
you know if that's what's maybe maybe we
should do a taste test there's an idea
right i'm always willing to eat we'll
get all the turkeys knock ourselves
right out
how about you make stuffing out of the
stuffing flavored bread then it's going
to be really
that's a magic really mind blowing right
there wow okay cooking tips from
mercedes martinez mercedes this is good
stuff
good to see you again this morning
bye bye all right